so hi my name is Arthur black
and here is my colleague demeaning to
shed Sookie we are working in data
science team in linear exertion Gary
polska which is one of the leading media
groups in Poland so the most famous
brand in our group's portfolio is on at
PL especially on at homepage and in on
earth we believe that if we recommend
our users articles which are in line
with their interest we maximize our
profits code because they will read more
of articles so let's talk about our
users our users visit on that homepage
to satisfy the needs for information and
there are over 11 million of real users
per month so by real users I mean that
the real people not the cookies or
devices so it's easy to imagine that in
such a big population the user interest
differs so we can divide our users into
groups with similar interest and that
implies the fact that we have to prepare
as many version of on that homepage as
many groups we distinguished so we can
define this problem as following we have
a content pool which is a set of
articles and we have to prepare
recommendation so it means that we have
to select a subset of articles from our
content pool and more about strategies
how to maximize our performance by
selecting articles will tell you the
Minich so can you hear me okay so when
it comes to the strategy as you probably
imagine there are many different
approaches we can adopt here and some of
the more obvious ones probably already
coming to your mind like
why don't we look at the users interest
based on his historical activity and
then try to recommend just items that
are similar to to those however this
comes with a couple of pretty big
problems the first one is called called
filter bubble where basically the user
is stuck in this loop of always being
recommended articles which are similar
to what he has read in the past and
there is no diversity in that and the
second problem is the user call start
problem where we don't really have a
clear strategy for new users since we
don't have a history for them so this
solution at least in the most need naive
implementation will not satisfy us so
the next pretty obvious solution is to
just always recommend the top and best
performing articles based on their
history but this also has some
disadvantages because in that setting
usually what gets its way to the top are
like particles with catchy titles all
these materials that have been popular
for some time but everyone has read them
and are familiar with them whereas what
we don't see are for instance some new
trends that are still rising maybe some
breaking news that we really want to
show to the user because they're
important as well as just materials
expressing different opinions so this
problem is usually called the majority's
tyranny
where is the majority that dictates
probably usually most or all of the
content that is visible whereas on the
bottom here we see a lot of unexplored
potential so clearly we need something a
bit more sophisticated than that and
this is where the multi unbounded
problem comes in and so to understand
this multi-armed bandit problem imagine
that you are in a casino with row of
slots machines and you decide to try to
win some money on them and then please
also assume that you can actually win
some money using some of these machines
but you don't know
once these are so some of them might
completely rip you off and waste your
time and money while others could
potentially make you rich and
furthermore assume that you only have a
specific number of trials during a given
time step so for instance for today you
might only play 25 you might perform
only 25 trials so what would you do in
such a scenario well if you're like me
you probably start with something very
naive like trying each of the machines
just once and seeing what comes out so
let's say this is the result that we get
and surely our uncertainty about these
articles has decreased a little bit but
I think you'll agree that this is way
too little information to really start
acting in a confident manner so let's
say we continue like that we try to be
really fair so we split all the trials
equally and perhaps we get something
like that
so now our uncertainty has turned into
somewhat of an estimate about how a
given machine is performing which is
represented by the smiley faces and so
based on this knowledge that we have
accumulated we can for instance decide
that for the next time step we will only
focus on the first three machines
therefore probably winning more money
with our new set of trials so what I've
just given you is a definition of the
multi-armed bandit problem as well as a
simple strategy to deal with that
problem so the problem more formally is
defined as choosing K items out of n
possible items in every time step T so
that our reward is maximized whereas the
strategy is mainly concerned with the
questions of how do we really choose the
subset in each time step and more
importantly how do we first of all store
and second how do we update the
estimates for the articles as as you
will see this might be done in a number
of different ways so now coming back to
our news recommendation scenario we can
reformulate it as a multi-armed bandit
problem we need to make just a few
simple connections first of all
the slot machines become the articles
that we recommend the player is the
recommendation engine each time step is
the moment where a user enters our web
page and wants to read some articles the
number of trials is basically the number
of articles that we can recommend on the
web page and finally for reward we have
a click or some other kind of engagement
on the part of user and penalty is lack
of such engagement so this also remember
one important fact that when we think of
of this as a multi unbounded problem we
need to remember that the recommendation
engine only selects the subset of the
articles whereas the laying on the
machine you could say is done by the
user himself so now that we have
formally defined our problem we can now
focus on some specific solutions to this
problem and this will be in a Christian
complexity epsilon greedy bandit youcb
bandit and thumbs on sampling so
starting with a simplest one which is
epsilon greedy to understand it we can
go back to our example with the top and
approach a greedy approach but then add
a little tweak to it which is that for
some of the articles at the top we swap
them with a random selection from the
entire list specifically we might choose
some article which is at the bottom of
or a completely new one so as you can
see this will answer our problem of
exploring new articles when they appear
as well as countering the tyranny of the
majority and more formally which was the
epsilon value between 0 and 1 usually a
much closer to 0 and then with
probability 1 minus epsilon which is the
most popular article available otherwise
which was a random article from the
entire content pool so agreed as I said
it's
as you can see it's quite simple
approach and therefore it comes with a
number of disadvantages which will be
shown by two scenarios first imagine
that we have a new article entering the
content pool that we want to explore
very intensively in the beginning
because we know that is for an instance
a very important event that has happened
and we want the user to see it very
often
however our exploration will be limited
to epsilon because that's the value that
we have set and we cannot really go
beyond that and on the other hand if we
have an article that we know is really
bad and maybe we don't even want to show
it to the user anymore we will still be
showing it because of the epsilon
precisely so this epsilon value which is
fixed causes us to have very little
flexibility in our exploration so how
can we make this better so here comes
the next plan deed which is UCB and the
way it works again we can start with the
top and list but this time we will give
a very huge optimism boost to the new
articles so much so that they will end
up in the beginning at least they will
end up even higher in our ranking then
the well-established well-performing
articles so more formally our new rank
is defined as the sum of performance
which is just the greedy part the top
end part and optimism which like I said
it starts at infinity but it quickly
decreases as we show the article more
and more so that given article has to
rely only on its performance and C is
the parameter that will balance the two
so like I said this might help us with
lack of flexibility in exploration
however UCB has its own caches first of
all it's more complex than epsilon
greedy you have multiple in
implementation that you can
use for that but the biggest Roebuck is
that on the other hand relative to
absolute on greedy now the exploitation
phase might be too strong and what I've
been by that perhaps I will it will be
weighted by this example so imagine we
have three fresh new articles which of
course start at the top due to the
optimism and then they get distributed
in the list based on how they really
perform so imagine that it happens that
one of the articles ends up at the very
bottom of the list or somewhere on the
bottom so in the case of UCB this
article will not be shown again at all
and in a way we might say that this is
what we wanted right we explored the
article and we proved that it's not
performing well so why bother but the
problem is that in our scenario of news
recommendation the situation might be
more dynamic than that so we might
expect that some of these articles might
start performing better perhaps simply
as a matter of time or because of some
other circumstance so in short their
performance in time is dynamic and we
have to somehow account for that whereas
UCB really doesn't so you see we have
sort of fallen into the opposite extreme
relative to Epsilon a greedy and so the
question is how can we find that balance
between these two and probably you
already are suspecting that some some
sampling will allow us to to find that
balance so the biggest advantage of
thomson sampling which is the most
complex algorithm of the three is that
it provides us with much better and
complete estimates for the articles so
whereas with the other bandits all we
had was just a simple single number
representing for instance the
probability that a given article will be
clicked now with them some sampling we
have a whole distribution function for
each and every article and the cool
thing about this function
is that it can be updated based on how
the article is really performing so we
can see that we start with a completely
uniform distribution which represents
our maximum uncertainty about this
article so we know nothing about it and
then based on the trials that we perform
we might update this function so that it
starts for instance in a case of a well
performing article it starts queuing to
the right and then we can even update it
more so that as you see the peak becomes
narrower which represents our increasing
confidence in this articles performing
well and on the other hand we can do a
symmetric operation where we skew the
the distribution to the left and this
represents our believe that this article
will not perform well and how do we
chose the articles in each time step we
simply have to sample each of the
articles distribution so we obtain some
samples then we sort them and just
select the top k top k articles so more
formally we take advantage here of the
base theorem which among other things
allows us to estimate the posterior
probability based on prior probability
and observation which is quickest
illustrated this way and in our case we
use a better prior which is really handy
because it has two parameters a and B
that can be used to directly influence
the way which in which the function will
be skewed so as I said this algorithm is
the most complex of the three and some
statistical knowledge is certainly
required to to understand and and
effectively use it and also the
implementation from the technical side
might be well certainly it's more
demanding that the other two so
summarizing Bandits as a whole I hope
you've seen that they can really help us
with problems we had namely that the
problem of new articles majority's
tyranny and filter bubble and depending
on the variant it can be quite easy to
implement them whereas the drawbacks
first of all you've seen that in every
case we had some parameters that need to
be tuned be it epsilon C for the
optimism or the prior function for
thumbs on something we also need some
amount of traffic for the Bundys to work
decently simply because of their
statistical nature and lastly we can't
really use the bandit to recommend
articles on a single user level so we
have to work on a level of a group or a
segment of users because otherwise the
feedback would be too sparse thanks as
the meaning mention articles the news
recommendation problem is a dynamic one
so to understand why this dynamic we
need to understand that every article
has its own life cycle so there are the
kind of articles like news or gossips
which popularity increasing and reach
the peak of the performance just after
they are published and after that the
their popularity is decreasing in time
in the other words who wanna raise about
yesterday's weather and also there are
articles like which performance is more
stable in time and the example of that
article can be history article because
you know the history doesn't change as
the weather does and also we have
articles which are getting popular only
seasonally like
article about how to avoid the bad
effects of air pollution in winter okay
and to address this problem of changing
trends of articles by multi-armed bandit
algorithm we can we know we can just
adjust our stat window because we know
that a multi-armed bandit algorithm
makes its decision which articles to
select based on stats which it
accumulated in previous trials so to to
catch the changing trends in article
popularity we can just use only a piece
of stats which are our most actual also
we know and Domenic show us three
different types of algorithm and we know
that each type of type needs to to tune
a parameter which balance the
exploitation and exploration for epsilon
greedy is of course epsilon for UCB is C
parameter and for Thomson something it's
priors also we can tune the stats window
lengths and only in this example we have
a 40 configuration so it's another
problem that how to choose the best
configuration for our algorithm in the
mall optimum in the most optimal way
because you know the methods popular
methods like a baby testing doesn't
aren't efficient enough so we decided to
build a simulator and we in this
environment we can simulate how our
algorithm which part
cooller configuration will work so to
explain you concept of this simulator
let's start what happens in a single
trial so we know that we have a Content
pool and we know that we have an
algorithm and that algorithm just
selecting a subset of articles from the
content pool and his decision is based
on stats which was accumulated in the
previous trials so algorithm prepared
the offer which is a subset of articles
from content pool based on knowledge and
estimated performance also we know that
articles have their own life cycle and
we can generate the data of life sight
which represents the dead life cycle in
this way that it also represents the
user interaction and we can just compare
our offer and we can see what results we
got so this important part of this
simulation is that our algorithm doesn't
see the life cycle data is just to get
our results so we in this way we get
stats of the this trial and we know
which which article get what performance
and also we got total payout of this
offer so we know that algorithm in this
trial get some reward and after we
repeat many trials we can say how well
our algorithm with particular
configuration perform in general so we
can
is a single run of simulation and we can
repeat that for as many algorithm as
many we want as when a configuration we
want to test and after that we can
choose the best one which maximized our
profit so if you interested how our
approach is is working in real world you
can just visit our on a dot PL home page
because it's fully published by using
with users of this approach so if you
want to know more about our approach to
recommendation system to personalization
you can also read our paper and there
are a lot of more details and the there
are presented in a lot of a lot more
formal way also if you have any
questions you can just ask us and the
last thing I hope that after this talk
when somebody ask you what's your
favorite bandit you don't say it Robin
Hood or Jack Sparrow you just say
multi-armed bandit thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much any questions okay
okay I try thank you for the
presentation I have one maybe two
questions first of all which of the
algorithm is implemented and what's the
influence on the loading time of the
page so we have actually tried all three
of these algorithms so the way we worked
was basically that first we run the
simulations and then we conducted a B
tests on the selected configurations and
if they proved to be better which they
did then we deployed them on the whole
of traffic but right now we are only
using some some sampling because we've
seen that it's the best one and as to
the loading time it doesn't really
matter because of the way our
recommendation system is built there's
no difference yeah yeah if there is a
difference I think it's very very small
so
my question is still able to manually
select the articles so for instance you
have like sponsored article which you
want to put on the main carousel banner
for instance for one day I was able to
manipulate that yes so the
recommendation system that we use has
the ability of pinning which is
basically that you can specify okay put
this article on the second position and
keep it there whereas all the other
positions are managed by the Bandit okay
are there any challenges left for you
when it comes to the main page or you
are pretty satisfied with the current
Thompson sampling recognition well there
are some challenges I'm not sure how
much we can disclose that but you know
there is always a fight to optimize and
make our system better so but the
results are pretty great so it's working
now is working fine and so that's the
next steps okay so thank you again
[Applause]